oh I have a map so this is Florida
everyone has a Florida map yeah and it's
right here Wow oh my gosh our parents
said let's do Christmas in Florida
you're in this awesome house it was
super open like me right on the golf
course
- yeah it was like around this cool lake
we want to see if there's fish in there
there and then when I caught the fish
best day
Brent's wearing the most epic sweatshirt
that's ever been created yeah but
seriously look at your hair man that is
a bowl cut deluxe this was the hair to
have and now the late 80s Early 90s
oh yeah that's what's so great about
those old cameras and I would like
burning in there exactly yep there's
definite angle to the balls it's a
science you gotta that is so cool of a
date stamp
scarily accurate yeah we did a really
good job they'd really nailed the chair
oh yeah the time stamp relevant really
the fish is I'll give that a golf club
wonderful piece this one was at a water
park looking at this photo does bring my
good memories
who is this though I don't know what
this person is it could be someone that
we just met it could be like a long-lost
cousin I would love to go back to this
memory just be great do I have to wear
that bathing suit though nothing bucks
as well I know it's not real but like
you can recreate it and yeah you so
subtle takes you back you still get the
same memory feel from seeing that you
can always go back to Florida to make
new memories you know bring your family
and make new memories yeah we can kind
of tell them stories oh when I was in
Florida this is what we did
we can times we create that like yeah so
I was actually on the way to the zoo and
I had to take my camel with me my mom
had her boom box so she was like hey
that's the Barney with a boom box I have
on like a little tail or sue the velcro
sneakers were in since I couldn't tie my
shoes my first time going to Florida was
such a huge like I opener and being able
to see this again really took me back in
time here is pigeon-toed oh my god hey
dude it was like awesome it felt like
childhood again so I really feel like it
was I don't know a nice memory I matter
what age you go you're gonna have you
have something something for everybody
in Florida you can't go back in time but
you can't go back to Florida
yeah 1994 Florida